a 60 Minutes interview with former
acting FBI director Andrew McCabe is
prompting lawmakers to gear up for
possible hearings into his very
explosive comments
McCabe told Scott Pelley last night
about a chaotic period in the FBI's
Russia investigation he says that he was
worried about the president's possible
ties to Russia so he opened not one but
two investigations after mr. Trump fired
his boss FBI director James Comey McCabe
also confirms there were discussions
about secretly recording the president's
words the White House said before last
night's broadcast Andrew McCabe was
fired in total disgrace from the FBI
because he lied to investigators on
multiple occasions including under oath
the statement claimed he quote has no
credibility mccabe was fired just before
he was set to retire he's considering a
lawsuit to recover his full benefits and
will publish a book tomorrow major
Garrett is at the White House with the
potential impact of that interview major
good morning good morning Andrew McCabe
told 60 minutes he launched those two
investigations just one day after
President Trump fired James Comey in
part to find out if the president was
trying to undermine the ongoing Russia
investigation and McCabe said if the FBI
hadn't taken that action it would not
have been doing its job Andrew McCabe
said the days after President Trump
fired former FBI director James Comey
were chaotic and confusing as he and
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
discussed the president's motivations
Rosenstein made an extraordinary
suggestion the Deputy Attorney General
offered to wear a wire into the White
House he said I never get searched when
I go into the White House I could easily
wear a recording device they wouldn't
know it was there now he was not joking
he was absolutely serious and in fact he
brought it up in the next meeting we had
I never actually considered taking him
up on the offer I did discuss it with my
general counsel and my leadership team
back at the FBI after he brought it up
the first time the point of Rosenstein
wearing the wire into a meeting with the
president was what
what did he hope to obtain I can't
characterize what rod was thinking or
what he was hoping at that moment but
the reason you would have someone wear a
concealed recording device would be to
collect evidence and in this case what
was the true nature of the president's
motivation in calling for the firing of
Jim Comey the general counsel at the FBI
and the leadership team you spoke with
said what about this idea I think the
general counsel had a heart attack when
he got up off the floor he said I that's
a bridge too far we're not there yet
the Justice Department has denied
Rosenstein authorized the use of a wire
to record the president on another
matter this concerning mr. Trump's
skepticism of US intelligence McCabe
recalled hearing a startling example
from an FBI official who met with the
president the president launched into
several unrelated diatribes one of those
was commenting on the recent missile
launches by the government of North
Korea and essentially the president said
he did not believe that the North
Koreans had the capability to hit us
here with ballistic missiles in the
United States and he did not believe
that because President Putin had told
him they did not President Putin had
told him that the North Koreans don't
actually have those missiles and US
intelligence was telling the president
wad intelligence officials in the
briefing responded that that was not
consistent with any of the intelligence
our government possesses to which the
president replied I don't care I believe
Putin President Trump came to believe
North Korea possessed those ballistic
missiles and will attend a second summit
with North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
later this month to try to achieve some
progress toward denuclearization
meanwhile the Russia investigation
continues McCabe told 60 minutes
he kept memos of all of his interactions
with the president and his conversations
and those memos Anthony have been turned
over to Special Counsel Robert Muller
Major Senator Lindsey Graham on on Face
the Nation yesterday
the Judiciary Committee will investigate
in McCabe's claims that the Deputy
Attorney General floated the idea of
invoking the 25th amendment to remove
the president so how's this gonna play
out well Lindsey Graham is not just any
ordinary Republican senator he's
chairman of the Judiciary Committee as
chairman he can call an oversight
hearing and he is made clear to our
colleague Margaret Brennan on Face the
Nation he intends to do just that as we
heard in the open he believes this
suggestion amounts to something
approximating an administrative coup and
he wants to get to the bottom of what
either Rosen Stein did or didn't do and
if McCabe is telling the truth
Anthony major Garrett at the White House
thanks major